your ambition if you have any sense is
actually to become competent so the
lesson to young people is don't take a
job for the money take a job for what
you're learning I've always been
fascinated by the Dark Side of human
nature what happens when you're an adult
and you want to change your brain
intuition is an intellectual factor I
realized one day what was missing was
confidence I have waited my whole life
for this moment do you want to be
competent and dangerous or do you want
to be vague and useless we learn from
our mistakes mistakes are opportunities
to get smarter be humble and take a look
at something you've got to be persistent
you put yourself together and your life
does get better and richer and more
abundant do yourself a favor and look
back and realize that in a short period
of time you're going to be creating and
working at a level that's far more
efficient and productive than before